as you look back and reflect on
2023 what sort of of memories highlight
stand out for you well one of the big
highlights stands out for me is my dad
used to have an expression he'd say Joey
a jobs about a lot more than the
paycheck it's about your dignity it's
about respect so many people through the
Midwest and and in the center of the
country their their factors are shipped
overseas the last couple times out and
and they were losing Hope and
Faith all right people we are back happy
New Year everybody I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Ruben report it is January 2nd in
the year 2024 and if you thought as I
did that 2023 flew by quickly just wait
until you see what happens over the next
364 days it is going to be a speed demon
of a year for many many reasons which
we're going to kind of set up today as
always we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals if you want to join
us for the postgame show Ruben report.
locals.com you can get comments and
questions in and uh we will talk
privately that's what we do after the
show if you join us over there uh the
theme for today is do you believe in
yourself or do you believe in the system
that's it that is my theme for the year
that is the Divide right now do you
think that you have some autonomy over
your life some control over your
emotions your feelings your family your
community and do you have the
wherewithal and the energy to fix things
for yourself to the best of your ability
or do you think you can just kind of
Outsource that to the system a system by
the way that I would say uh over the
last couple years in particular uh has
not been all too kind to the individual
to you to me to our families and
everything else A system that seems to
be collapsing and is being attacked
Every Which Way and yet a certain amount
of people uh still think that the system
is in it for them so that's going to be
our theme we will lay it out using
evidence via both video and audio and
before we do that I want to show you a
tweet that I put up this morning uh
Phoenix sent it to me and he sent me
back my own tweet he said it it had gas
is that what it is it was gas which
means that means super duper uh for the
uh for the kids out there this is what I
wrote 2020 20 2020 2024 thought the
easiest possible sorry the easiest thing
possible is to be an over over the top
alarmist especially if it fits your
narrative and gets you Clicks in cash so
while yes there is an awful lot to worry
about no Southern border mid East War
Strife on our streets online censorship
fenel crisis to likely presidential
candidates that most of the country
hates Etc I do believe there is cause
for hope the human Spirit Longs for
freedom and The Human Condition also has
an innate desire for truth while the
conditions are set to crush both freedom
and in truth there will be a renewed
Spirit amongst those who are awake as
opposed to woke to fight for these
Eternal values it will be hard to see
and even harder to accomplish but I
truly believe if those of us who want to
live in a world that we had yet have
almost totally given up we just have to
find each other and figure out how to
work together it will happen at school
boards community centers sports leagues
and places of worship then over time it
will scale up our ancestors found it in
themselves to build the greatest country
in the world has ever known and now it's
our turn to rebuild it for ourselves or
we can just fight on Twitter empower the
grifters and burn it all down the choice
is yours all right so that's where I'm
at that is my message for the beginning
of the year do you believe in yourself
or do you believe in the system and it's
not just it's not just yourself will
there be a series of people we can call
them the sens makers who will Arise at
this very precarious moment that we all
feel that we are in right rolling into
an election year all of the the things
that I mentioned in that tweet this very
strange moment that we can all we all
feel like America is kind of Sliding
Away Western values are sliding away
we're watching violence in our streets
violence across the world will there be
a sensemaker class that will fix it or
will we just again Outsource our
decisions over our lives and then hand
it to a bunch of grifters who will just
make some money along the way that is
the challenge so I want to start today
with a little bit of uh somebody who
believes that there is uh who has been a
sens maker whether I agree with him on
everything or not uh and someone who I
think is a little bit confused about the
issues uh Seth mcmarlin who of course
created Family Guy and a million other
uh TV shows he was the guest on Bill
Mars podcast on Club random uh over the
weekend and they started talking about
the vaccines now for all of you that are
he's frustrated with Bill on what he
says about Republicans and all that
stuff that's just fine but he has been
pretty good on vaccine hesitancy and
vaccine injuries and all of that
McFarland doesn't seem to be uh getting
the information that a whole bunch of us
have been dropping and watch this
exchange if you already but if you
already had the disease you have natural
immunity we didn't see we didn't seem to
believe in that that was debunked though
I mean that was that don't you know
people have' had Co four or five times I
do that's not natural immunity there's
no immunity there you've had Co five
times probably because you had too many
vaccines I didn't have Co did you did
the vaccine gave you co uh well that's
certainly nothing unscientific about the
fact that the vaccine which does weaken
you in order to strengthen you says do
all vaccines exactly yeah but while
you're in a weakened State yes that's
why so many people like me got it did
not have it while the thing was raging
and I was taking zero precautions cuz I
was never that afraid of it but that's
anecdotal like I've had every booster
there is anecdotal that yeah and I have
never had Co I get a flu shot once a
year I haven't had the flu in 20 years
right well I haven't E I don't get a flu
shot okay so this is all anecdotal but
but but you know the difference between
anecdotal and and statistical I do and
and statistically you you still have a
90% better chance of not being
hospitalized not dying if you're
vaccinated oh well that but that's
assuming all people are alike and that
is one of the Giant FES in your way of
thinking we are not all alike yes I
would recommend and have recommended the
covid vaccine for the high-risk people
like if you're 90 or fat get it
absolutely you need it some people don't
but you had jokovic didn't need it but
you had Aaron Rogers didn't need it but
you had something like 1900 kids who
died of Co during the pandemic I don't
okay there there's a lot to unpack there
and I think it illustrates that kind of
decent people I have no doubt although
I'm going to be a little more critical
of Seth McFarland and he generally is
kind of a woke Progressive Lefty which
is really disappointing because he's
created great irreverent Politically
Incorrect comedy like family guy so it's
a little bizarre connecting those two
things two decent people can see things
very differently but the essence of it
is one of them bill is showing
skepticism right skepticism towards the
vaccines the idea that the government
could force you to do it and everything
else that you have autonomy over your
body and your mind and I thought that
was what the left was all about my body
my choice that sort of thing and that we
should uh each make choices that are
right for oursel well Seth wants the
sort of control everyone should get the
VX he's also sort of making things up
like people got covid over and over who
weren't VX well some of them did I I
think I've had covid at least twice I'm
not vaxed but I didn't get vaxed and I
survived and it was my choice the idea
that we should just be following the
system A system that again after all of
the lockdowns and all of the mandates
and everything else uh wasn't looking
out for us right that has led us now to
a generation that is fatter and children
who have delayed speech and all of the
years of learning that are lost and or
have been lost and everything else uh
but then it got a little more testy
between the two of them because they got
into it about our government agencies
and whether in fact they are looking out
for us okay but some but some people
million people things are and you cannot
prevent that you can though I mean you
you you you can prevent at what cost
what's the cost of getting a vaccine
what what's why is why what's well the
fact that you the fact that you don't
even have a clue what's the cost of
getting a vaccine that you don't know
the answer to that no you're you're
you're you're you you completely want to
shut your eyes to the fact that there
are repercussions to all medical
interventions incl including a vaccine
all vaccines they come they say side
effects just like every medication does
you can see in the literature they can't
write it on the back you know on the
vaccine so you have to dig them and and
of course there is a vaccine court
because so many people have been injured
this is not a screed to say don't do
vaccines I'm not against doing vaccines
I'm against doing vaccines that I don't
think I need I should be able to decide
that for myself inside my body we
disagree on the fact that I think that
the public health infrastructure despite
being absolutely inadequate prior to
covid did as good a job as they could
have done during Co and it pisses me the
off when I see people sh on when I see I
see it must because you like like
steered it all the way back to that
again oh McFarland like you think after
covid that the public health SE sector
the apparatus that they did as good a
job as they could have you have more of
belief in that thing right now you have
more of a belief in the system the
system that was firing nurses for not
wanting to get vaxed the system that put
all sorts of people out of work and did
all sorts of crazy psychotic things of
children and masks and everything else
that's the system that you believe in uh
also when he asks what's the cost of
getting a vaccine well there are we
don't know the exact numbers but there
are undoubtedly at least hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people all
over the world who have been vaccine
injured you probably know some I know
some like that that absolutely is real
why would you just trust the system by
the way right now now and we'll get into
a bit more on uh immigration in just a
second but right now we have all sorts
of people rampaging through our borders
we were closing our borders from state
to state because of covid and now people
just run through our borders like what
what how could you believe in the system
but I think that what that illustrates
is the divide that we're going to see
more and more of in 2024 someone who's
sort of anti-woke and skeptical of
government and someone who's kind of
Proke and thus ends up shilling for the
government because once you're woke you
sort of end up believing in the power
you they say they're fighting for the
power but they actually end up
believing in the power and they want to
Outsource more of their own decisions
all Bill is saying there is hey I'm
however old I am I take care of myself I
want to make those decisions for them
myself and Seth Seth is in essence
saying no no there's a system out there
that I somehow believe in I'm not
exactly sure why uh but it should be
able to take care of you so do you
believe in the system I'm going to drive
this thing home today do you believe in
the system or do you believe in yourself
I'm now going to uh jump over to moik
boox for a second but then we're going
to bust out a little Jordan Peterson Sam
Harris because they got into it too and
I think it will also illustrate that
divide quite well uh you guys know that
60% of us pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
her find it in your grocery aisle every
day guys there's a better way I want to
tell you about moink that is Moo plus
oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grassfish beef and lamb pastured pork
and chicken and sustainable wild caught
Alaskan salmon straight to your door
moink Farmers Farm like our grandparents
did and as a result moink meat tastes
like it should because the Family Farm
Does It Better the moink difference is a
difference you can taste and you can
feel good knowing you're helping Family
Farms stay financially independent as
well you choose the meat delivered in
every box like ribbe eyes to chicken
breast to pork chops to Salmon plays and
much more plus you can cancel anytime
Shark Tank host Kevin o called moink ba
moinks bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got moink
keep American farming going by signing
up at Mbox docomo right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but only
for a limited time MK box.com box.com
rubben and now back to me okay so this
divide that I am talking about that you
you can make decisions for yourself that
you can use your mind and critical
thinking to decide what is best for you
and your family versus there's a system
in place and it will tell you what to do
uh I think we just Illustrated a little
bit of that divide between uh Bill and
Seth McFarland and by the way I suspect
that they're probably friends outside of
that and these are the the arguments
that we should be having in public in a
healthy Society uh but now I want to
show you uh Sam Harris on Jordan
Peterson's podcast now Sam and I used to
be friends I suppose we are we are not
friends anymore I will tell that story
perhaps in the postgame show today how
that thing ended up uh not not important
but the last time I played a video of
Sam a couple months back I think I said
that we weren't going to show videos of
him anymore because it just brings me no
pleasure because of the personal side of
this uh but I thought I saw this video
over the weekend and it was just like it
illustrates this this notion so
perfectly that I think it's worth
showing so here's Sam Harris and Jordan
Peterson this is on Jordan's podcast and
Sam talking about why Elon Musk bought
Twitter now you guys know my feelings on
this Elon bought Twitter he didn't have
to do this he's sending people you know
humans to space working on a Mars
operation he's building electric cars
neuralink a whole bunch of other stuff
uh I think he actually believes in free
speech and that has been the ethos of
the company since he has bought it uh
but listen to Sam's take on it and I
think you'll see how we're connecting it
to everything else look at what Twitter
has done to Elon 's life right it's just
you know Elon used to be a friend you
know he's somebody I knew reasonably
well
um you know his engagement with Twitter
has
been catastrophic for him as a person
from my point of view I mean it's just
it's clearly a compuls compulsion I mean
he was so addicted to it that he felt he
needed to buy the platform um but it is
a you know his use of it has been so
irresponsible and uh produced such
forget about the harm he's produced in
other people's lives uh how and nothing
I'm saying now has relates to changes
he's made to the platform I mean that's
that's a separate thing that we can talk
about you know I'm I've always been
agnostic as to whether or not he could
actually improve Twitter as a as a
platform and he may yet wind up doing
that but I'm just talking about the way
he has personally used it as a user of
the platform and the way he's interacted
with people and boosted signal boosted
massively um the profiles of anonymous Q
andon lunatic trolls right I mean he's
he's been completely Cavalier in who he
interacts with all the while knowing
that anyone he boosts suddenly gets you
know a million followers and and has a
platform that they otherwise couldn't
imagine having um so I look at him and I
think okay if if someone of his talent
who has so many other good things to do
with his 24 hours in any given day uh is
is this derailed by this platform you
know is this is using it this
compulsively to the
obvious degradation of his reputation in
most circles that so interesting his
obvious degradation in most circles that
count that sounds like quite a quite an
elitist statement uh my position is
obvious the guy has bought this thing
because because he has been defending
Free Speech it's what he spends all day
long talking about on the platform and
putting up polls on what their policies
should be and should we allow Alex Jones
back on or not etc etc right should we
allow Donald Trump back on etc etc he
didn't have to do it I think it's a
pretty dim view to say he bought Twitter
because he was addicted to Twitter like
he just bought a little toy he bought
something that is allowing us to see
more Truth Now does that mean that
sometimes there might be more mean
people on there and more mean trolls and
they're going to say bad things about
Dave Rubin and a whole bunch of other
people of course but they existed there
before uh so the idea I mean he used the
word catastrophic that elon's purchase
of Twitter Twitter if you even if you
were to just look at the events of the
last three months the videos that we've
been able to see the horrific videos and
and all of the barbarity and all of the
stuff that would not have traveled as
easily on other platforms because they
would have been censored and they
wouldn't have fit the narrative and all
of those things it's like he's allowing
more truth to get out there but I think
a certain set of people who really
believe in the system they don't want
that much truth out there right they
don't want that many voices out there as
Sam is saying he wants a certain the
certain circles in certain circles
people don't like Elon that much I think
the people like Elon that's the thing so
it's interesting because Elon is sort of
like Bill Maher right like he's just
kind of like a common sense rational
liberal you may not like what his voting
record is or anything else but I think
you could put say an Elon Musk and a
Bill Maher in the same camp of we're
trying to figure it out more speech is
better than less speech Let's be
skeptical and then I think you could
take another bucket and that would be
the Seth McFarland Sam Harris bucket and
it's kind of like no we'll figure it out
for you guys and our corrupt
institutions are kind of well we won't
even call them corrupt but our
institutions are kind of good even
though they're woke and we're always
fighting the woke and everything else so
that seems to be The Divide uh but the
question is really I would say because
Sam says that Elon is amplifying people
who is Elon amplifying now we I was
looking around this morning I couldn't
find any qinon people that he's
amplifying I have no doubt he has
messaged and retweeted people uh that I
don't agree with he's retweeted and he's
commented on on me so some people don't
like me okay he's just out there doing
stuff but what is he really focusing on
now that he has Twitter well I think you
could just look at his pin Twitter that
Elon Musk of course I'm talking about
and look at this almost no one seems to
be aware of the immense size and
lightening growth of this issue
according to the Mayors it is already
overwhelming essential services in New
York Chicago and other cities and what's
he referring to well he's retweeting
this from data Hazard since August there
are officially more arriving each month
than there are children being born to
American Mothers and these are just the
official encounters we don't know how
many avoided detection so of course what
Elon is Shining Light on this is his pin
tweet that means if you go to his page
that is the main tweet that is sitting
up there Conor can you put the the data
back up for just a second we'll put that
chart up for you guys for just a second
so you can see what's happening now
there has been a massive massive spike
in illegal immigrants and the birth rate
in America kind of stays the same but
now it's getting to the point that we
are bringing in more illegals than we
have native births so when Sam says that
why did Elon get this and people in
certain circles don't like him look what
he's actually using the platform for
he's using the platform for good because
do you think they're going to cover that
on CNN today is that alarming like
that's seriously alarming they're more
illegals people we have no idea what
their beliefs are what their intentions
are or anything else now coming into our
country to set up shop they are now
multiplying faster than native born
Americans you think that's a problem of
course it is of course it is and by the
way you don't have to take my word for
it here is National border patrol
council president Brandon Jud detailing
the abject disaster happening at our
border right now what Authority do you
guys have to deport who can you Deport
or is it just largely at this point just
in processing and handing notices to
appear nobody nobody what we do is we
take individuals into custody we process
them for Deport proceedings but then we
turn around and we release them and what
what that does is that allows them to
travel wherever they want in the United
States it also allows them to disappear
into what Obama term the shadows of
society that's when they don't show up
to the court appearances all of these
people know that they have a very small
chance of actually receiving Asylum by
an immigration judge they know that
that's not going to happen so they don't
show up to their court appearance so
every single day that we release
thousands of of illegal immigrants into
our country we know that they're never
going to leave they're they're going to
be here to stay and then when you look
at the the how long it's going to be
before they even see an immigration
judge when you hear that do you believe
in the system do you believe that the
federal government is doing the right
thing at our border you've got border
agents literally saying hey we're
letting people in we process them and
then we know we just let them out into
the country and they don't show up for
their hearings because if they show up
their hearings they might be kicked out
so instead they just infiltrate the the
country so when Elon Musk posts a pin
tweet Shining Light on that that is good
because he is trying to say hey I'm an
American we have a problem here in
America and the system again do you
believe in your self or do you believe
in the system the system is failing but
there are some people I would say Seth
McFarland on the covid front uh Sam on
going after Elon it's sort of you are
running cover for a system that is
failing and I suspect that a lot lot of
the people who are coming into this
country are not going to be all too kind
to Sam's ideas when it comes to
criticizing religion and a bunch of
other stuff but let's put that aside for
a second so what else is the system
producing right now well in the
communist country it's its own country
at this point of California uh as of
yesterday as of January 1st they are
going to give free health insurance to
all illegal immigrants so starting
January 1st California will become the
first state in the nation to offer
health insurance to undoc dou umented
immigrants under the expansion more than
700,000 people between the ages of 26
and 49 will be eligible for medical cbsa
Rosio de takes a look at the new law and
how immigrant rights Advocates are
reacting immigrant rights Advocates
called the expansion of healthc care for
undocumented immigrants a major
milestone in California this is really
major step in in
California that immigrant immigrant
right
activists people who have gotten here
illegally who should not be here who are
are criminals by definition right once
you're you've broken the law to get in
you deserve nothing you have to go home
but it's framed immigrants rights
activists so that means
700,000 people in California right now
who produce nothing into the system
right they don't pay taxes into the
system they're here illegally again we
don't know what they think what they
believe we don't know what their
behaviors are we don't know how they
feel about religious minorities or gays
or women or anything else we're just
going to give them stuff and we know how
this works out when you take a bunch of
people who don't pay into the system
they are here illegally in the first
place they don't pay into the system and
then you give them stuff the good people
of those societies of those cities say
our Sanctuary cities right now like New
York and Chicago Etc they start getting
pissed boy wait a minute I'm paying into
the system I'm getting less there's more
crime there's more uh migrant housing
over here we don't know what these
people are doing there's more drugs on
the streets etc etc our homeless
shelters are closing because we're
putting illegals in there now there's
more homeless on the street like we know
what happens when you do this you might
want to look at what's going on in
Germany you might want to look at what's
going on in the UK or France when you do
this uh but California and by the way
California let's not forget California
has lost over a million people in the
last 3 years since Co I think it's about
1.5 million people now and the type of
people who have left have been major
earners they also have the Mansion tax
in California now which got enacted last
year so if you had a house that was over
say $4 million something like that they
were going to throw another tax on you
on top of that so all of the rich people
plus you have income tax there so the
rich people where did they go they took
their businesses and their skills and
their families and they're usually
law-abiding citizens as well and they
moved to Texas and they moved to
Tennessee and they moved to Florida so
now a place that has less resources in
the first place because the taxpayer and
the Ane people are getting the hell out
now they're giving more so then they're
they're crushing down more on the decent
middle class person who maybe doesn't
have the luxury to move or who hasn't
come around on on all these ideas yet
so I would bring this back Elon Musk
Bill Maher Jordan Peterson who sat there
very quietly and did not push back on
Sam he just let him speak and I think
that that probably was the most
effective way to do it they are not
rightwing Maniacs in any definition of
it I would say they are anti-woke they
are sane and they believe in the
individual and that is what the cultural
divide is all about right now but I
don't think that quite reflects our
political divide so let's shift this a
little bit because the political divide
right now seems to be about people who
believe in Law and Order and people who
do not believe in Law and Order right
you have a country or you don't so going
with the immigration thing for just a
moment here's Karin jeanpierre yes it's
a new year but look at this shirt she's
wearing I'm interested in this shirt
more than anything else but also she
says some stuff about immigration and
what we're seeing here at the border the
migration flow uh increased migration
flow certainly uh it you know it es and
flows and we're at a time of the year
where we're seeing more uh at the border
and it's not unusual this is an
immigration system that has been broken
for decades and the president has taken
this very seriously to try all right put
inside the the shirt for just a second
something interesting about a scarf with
like a big opening I don't know anyway
um oh it's just it's just a seasonal
thing it's just all of these thousands
and thousands of people about 800,000
since October 1st it's just seasonal you
know what I mean like it's chilly they
start moving up here and then you know
it'll e and flow and it's everything's
always been broken guys this we all know
this was not happening under Trump trump
didn't get the wall done but there was a
message sent out to the universe and the
message was don't come and then people
didn't
come but now the message is come and
they're coming all over everybody okay
and it's not good it's not good because
then we also it's not just that we have
a failure at the federal level and we
have a failure with the people that
they've hired right like then they have
these diversity Equity inclusion hires
like that woman who was only hired
because she's a black lesbian and she
just lies about everything but then even
in the cities you get these types of
people so Boston mayor Michelle Woo is
another one of these people now Michelle
Woo is an interesting character because
you would think that Asian people by and
large would not be woke because woke is
very anti-asian the same way it's
anti-jewish because Asian people much
like Jews have spent a lot of focus and
time on family and education and hard
work and there are traditions and values
that they bring to things that allow
them to succeed so they succeed at
higher levels than other communities and
that doesn't fit the intersectional
calculator and the whole woke thing I
know you guys know all this this is the
same woman uh who just a couple weeks
ago was two weeks ago ago right before
we left uh she was having a black and
brown holiday party for uh employees in
Boston okay uh well here she is uh
commenting on what's going on at the
border and what they're going to do over
there in Boston every person every human
being has the legal right to come to the
United States and seek Asylum or shelter
and um those policies have been in place
for a long time no lady no you don't you
can want Asylum uh but you can't just
show up and walk in and it's just it's
so staggeringly incredible that the
Democrat Party has has so gone off the
deep end that they have mainstreamed the
idea that you can just break the law you
can just show up come here and break the
law you can then harm the cities that
you're in for all the reasons that I
explained the stress that you put on the
system and that if you defend that that
somehow you're the good guy but you are
not the good guy why are they doing this
so the question always is why are they
doing this the road to hell is paav with
good intentions these are they just want
to help people and they especially want
to help brown and black people something
like that well one of their absolute
ideological tenants is tolerance and
inclusivity we all know that right that
tolerance and inclusivity everybody
should have everything all the time and
I suppose in some magical fairy land in
shangrala that that would work except as
GK Chesterton famously said tolerance is
a virtue of men who lack conviction
right you have to have a set of beliefs
and then you can see who fits into that
you can see who fits into the country
that you've built the home that you've
built the community that you've built
but if tolerance everybody oh you want
to murder my grandma you want to behead
my sister you want to rape the family
come on in this is not going to work out
well okay I think we all know that and
how do we know it well let's look at
some of the consequences of woke today
uh as you know they love promoting
genital mutilation here is video of our
new lieutenant colonel in the Army Brie
Fram explaining how important inclusion
is and you might notice something
interesting about
Bri so inclusion is a national security
imperative we fight today and we are
going to fight in the future using brain
power and if that brain who's going to
revolutionize the way we fight in space
we fight in cyber just happens to be in
a trans body you should want them all
serving alongside me Bri is a
dude Bri is a dude telling us that
inclusion is deeply important to our
national security that is complete
nonsense that is a man in a dress and
and I don't if you would like to be an
adult male and wear a dress and have
your friends and hang out and do all
your stuff that's just fine with me uh
but the idea that we've allowed this to
enter the top echelons of our military
institutions and then you have a man in
add dress explaining to us that
tolerance tolerance again and
inclusivity that these are National
Security issues this is a problem you
you were kind of into him weren't
you sorry Connor why would I start the
year off like that sorry I apologize um
this is a problem but again this has
infected all of the systems what do you
think will happen to a system where and
we by the way we know that the military
has gone fairly woke over the last
couple years anyway but what do you
think will happen to a system over time
that views tolerance and diversity as a
national security issue that puts that
really at the Pinnacle of of the of the
degrees of importance with which we
order things well then you might start
letting in people who are less qualified
you might start I don't know getting
taking your eye off the ball and being
like Oh you know there's a real threat
over there but how many trans people do
we have making less lunch today uh but
of course this fiddles through every
everything in society right now this one
is absolutely wild and we are definitely
buying tickets to this event this is
from The Daily Mail USA boxing to allow
transgender women to compete against
female boxers under certain conditions
from 2024 after introducing new policy
uh leave the headline up for just a
second what that should say is USA
boxing to allow men to compete against
female boxers under certain conditions
from 24 after introducing new policy we
are going we are going you find out okay
Brock I want you on this you find out
when they're having the men kick the
crap out of the women in the name of
Tolerance and diversity here in Miami we
are going getting first row tickets for
everybody so okay so what are they do
tolerance is at the top of this thing so
now we have men kicking the crap out of
women well what they also do of course
is decriminalize crime and reward you
actually for being a criminal so now
let's head over to Chicago can I get the
numbers on how many people were killed
over the New Year in Chicago it's
probably a good one um and mayor this is
new mayor Brandon Johnson and of course
you know Brandon Johnson he's the one
that replaced Lori Lightfoot who was
completely bananas Beetlejuice woman now
they get someone who's even further left
than him it's just great and here he is
and now who's he concerned about is it
the good taxpayer of Chicago the the guy
who's just trying to keep his family
safe and you know take care of his
property and everything else are you
going to take care of that guy maybe
give that guy some tax breaks and you
know help him flourish or are you going
to focus on the criminals and everything
else I think you know the answer in
order for us to have a better stronger
and safer Chicago it really requires the
full force of government we have stood
up an entire office dedicated to
re-entry so individuals who are
returning to our communities who have
been incarcerated because of failed
policies U we'll have a welcoming space
for them I've added a half a million
dollars for restoration and reparations
to address again the cycle of violence
yes yes okay reparations he's also going
to have a weal a well welcoming space
for the people who have been
incarcerated because of failed policies
I don't know maybe they murdered
somebody maybe they broke into a home
punched grandma in the face we're going
to take care of those people
interestingly this is rather fascinating
on New Year's Eve there were only 23
people shot in Chicago which you would
have thought at least 40 people two were
killed 23 shot so that's a pretty good
uh pretty good pretty good evening I
guess if you're in Chicago but you guys
know this what happens is these people
come up with all of the wrong ideas they
destroy the cities and then a certain
set what also happens it's not just like
the political Elite that push all this
nonsense but then a certain set of
celebrities and athletes also get out
there people who have gotten everything
you could ever want in life it would be
my dream my dream ladies and gentlemen
to play professional basketball for a
living I'd give it all up I'd give up
this coffee mug I'd give up this glass
I'd give up the the paper and the
Sharpie to play one NBA game that would
be it for me right then there's this guy
LeBron James and LeBron James is a
billionaire he is literally worth over a
billion dollars he's a pretty damn good
basketball player he's not Michael
Jordan there I've said it I don't know
that I've ever said that publicly before
Michael Jordan is still the greatest NBA
player ever six championships in in six
years right he went to the finals six
times won all six times LeBron's lost a
whole bunch of finals anyway uh LeBron
James is promoting Ed throughout the
system because he bows to China because
he loves vaccines because he will tell
you how racist this Society is as he a
black man becomes a billionaire and his
son becomes the highest paid player in
college basketball and here he is
fighting well it's a new he he well just
you listen just listen close just listen
closely job of of putting that thing
together from a social injustice
standpoint um us as as the players to be
able to use the NBA platform and us be
able to go out there and speak about a
cystic racism uh um you know police
brutality voter suppression everything
that was going on um gave us an
opportunity and we all stood in
solidarity with Milwaukee
Bucks cystic racism that's that's that's
one it's like a cystic zit that thing
just will not go away you could put uh
what's what's the zit medicine for that
they oy oxyclean no not oxylean not
oxyclean what was Accutane or what was
the one it was in like a pad like you'd
have it when you were a kid proa oh
proactive solution but there was another
one it was just like a pad generic what
the hell was that anyway it's systemic
not cystic you idiot but also he just
the way he just casually throws out
these things police brutality he doesn't
give you any numbers or any explanation
or talk about Behavior or anything else
police bre voter suppression I fairly
certain every black person in America is
allowed to vote I'm also pretty sure
that black people just like white people
and Latinos and everybody else can get
voter uh IDs can you know they have to
get on a plane and to get on a plane you
need an ID but you get it they just
promote him more and more and more and
he'll never speak about say the genocide
of the Muslim Wagers that is happening
in China because he's owned by China
because Nike and the contracts okay fine
uh but let's continue uh because it's
not just that they want to break
everybody's brains and import people to
collapse the system and make it so that
you won't know which way is up and you
won't have a dime to spare because
they're going to give health insurance
to everybody else they want to actually
socialize and I mean socialize like
bring in socialism the economy and they
want to end equality this is what it
really is about they want to end
equality the idea that there will be an
even playing field will all have started
in different places but the playing
field will be even and then you got to
work hard and you got to get a chance
and there's a little bit of luck
that's the freaking adventure of Life
they want to rip that up and they want
something else something called Equity
allow Kamala Harris this is a video from
a couple years ago uh it's an
interesting video she's wearing a mask
note her chair is a little bizarre but
listen to cala Harris explain what the
ultimate uh outcome of their Adventure
is
equality suggests often everybody should
get the same
thing well that often assumes everybody
started out in the same place
as opposed to equity which is everyone
should end up in the same
place and if you then understand not
everybody started out in the same place
you understand some people need
more so we all end up in the same place
that is socialism 101 before I comment
on that though I do want to address
something I was right there used to be
something called Oxy pads that it was
like this pad and it burned like hell
you put it on your face when you were a
kid and then apparently there's also a
clear Hill and then of course proactive
solution uh but as it relates to
equality and Equity she's telling you we
are socialists we are communists we want
everyone to end up in the same place
think how radically anti-human that is
some people have more LeBron James has
more than me I am not good enough to be
an NBA player although I did hit five
threes in our playoff game 15 points not
bad but I'm not an NBA player right I'm
not and it's okay he has an awful lot I
don't know that he really deserves all
of that but it's not my
right I don't it's not within my right
to take that from him so what does she
mean she wants everyone to be equal in
the end are you going to take all of
LeBron James stuff who also believes in
social justice and also believes in all
the nonsense that you believe in are you
going to take all of his money and
redistribute it throughout all of the
black and brown community and then
everyone will have the exact same stuff
as LeBron James it doesn't mean anything
what she means is there will be an elite
set of people who will have whatever
they want and everyone else will get
peanuts that's what she means but
there's a reason that they keep pushing
these ideas and that these ideas then
proliferate down throughout Society it's
because the sense making remember that's
where we started at the top of the show
The sensemaking in America has been
completely blown apart we have so few
people uh that are discussing any of the
issues honestly you just say things
right you just say cystic racism and you
don't know what you're talking about you
just say police brutality you just say
white supremacy you just say voter
suppression and then people are just
like my God the cystic racism and the
voter suppression and all the what's
another one they always talk about it's
the gender pay Gap so this video was was
going viral over the weekend this is
great this is from
2017 okay here's Rachel mattow over on
the televised mental institution known
as MSNBC talking about the gender pay
Gap this is seven years ago talking
about the gender pay Gap and watch her
get put in her place this is just so
beautiful women women in this country
still make 77 cents on the dollar for
what men make so
if women don't make less than men
actually if you start looking at the
numbers Rachel uh there are lots of
reasons for that wait wait no wait don't
tell me the reasons are do women make
less than men for doing the same work uh
no because wow okay well for example men
work men work an average of 44 hours a
week women work 41 hours a week men go
into professions like engineering
science and math that earn more women
want more flexible not math is hard yes
is it isn't women are making 77 cents on
the dollar that for for what men are
making so that's not true
every greedy businessman in America
would hire only women save 25% and and
be hugely and I love how passionate you
are I wish you were as right about what
you're saying as you are passionate
about it I really do for example so that
guy I I think his name is can you can we
try on this I think his name is Alex
kastanakis or kalistos or something he
used to be on CNN and I guess MSNBC and
a bunch of these things he was he was
actually he was a kind of right-leaning
political analyst I don't know what
happened to him but but you can see he's
calmly explaining things there that men
tend to work more men and women go into
different things men generally like
things more women like people more which
is why you're going to get more female
nurses and you're going to get more male
Engineers you don't see an awful lot of
women say I don't know diving into
septic tanks and cleaning them up
generally you don't Alex is it kalist
anakis we're going to try to find it or
someone can mention it in the chat so
men work more right and by the way
that's it's okay because generally what
that means is that women are child
rearing more as a general rule and it is
good to have a mother taking care of a
child that's a generally good thing so
men work more they do different things
and then at the end what he says so
beautifully oh her line don't tell me
the reasons isn't that like the most
perfect modern sort of liberal take on
things like I just say something crazy
women earn 70 cents on the dollar well
actually that's not true if I can give
you some information I don't want to
hear the reasons I'm a freaking liberal
I just said it this is a televis metal
institution what do you think we're
doing over here tell telling people the
truth but then the last line that that
Alex mentions uh he says a good
businessman if it was true that
everything was absolutely equal across
the board behaviors desires all of those
things and you could just hire women at
70 cents on the dollar that you would
hire a man for every business owner
every I would get rid of you what what
am I working with these idiots for I
would bring in chicks and save an awful
lot of money no offense guys you get the
point you get the point so they blow
apart everyone's brains we have very
very few sens makers to clean up some of
the mess and then you just get idiotic
people in power and speaking of idiotic
people in power the big story of course
that we missed uh during the Christmas
New Year's break was that Maine
Secretary of State Shena Bellow has
booted Donald Trump off the ballot uh
let's listen to miss Bell's explain why
she did just that
I am so mindful and I I said this in my
decision uh that it is unprecedented no
secretary of state has ever deprived a
presidential candidate of ballot access
based on section three of the 14th
Amendment but no presidential candidate
has ever engaged in
Insurrection and been disqualified under
section three of the 14th Amendment I am
so mindful of this thing that I just did
and nobody else has ever done it but I
did it because I'm mindful of the thing
that I just did and when you're mindful
of the thing that you just did you do
that thing and that's what I'm mindful
of so you know okay I hate people that
talk like that I cannot that whatever
that thing is I cannot stand it that
aside for just a moment so yes Donald
Trump has at least temporarily and this
just like the Colorado decision of
course this will get up to it'll
eventually get up to the Supreme Court
it has to get there and Trump Mo most
likely because the Supreme Court is
roughly sane will be put back on the
ballot and if these idiots if this
bellows woman and the Colorado person
who did this if they had if if Trump is
the one they fear the most then of
course they should not be doing this cuz
that is the thing that is fueling him
it's not his it's not his campaign right
he's not really campaigning it's not
it's not the the vision that he has for
the country or anything else it's the
it's the concept that he is under attack
that is what is lighting the fire under
the Trump thing uh but let's flash back
to that diversity Higher One More Time
here's cring jampier uh and what she's
mostly concerned about because you know
Trump's been removed from Main case in
Colorado what is is she worried that you
know in America were removing
presidential candidates from The Ballot
or could there be something else she's
worried
about has have a response to this
significant violent rhetoric um that
targeted the Colorado Supreme Court
Justices and Democrats following that
ruling um that would have kept that
would keep Donald Trump off the ballot
there some of that violent rhetoric has
come directly in response to his own
posts on social media but there were
concerns raised about that and that's
spreading on social media on violent
language and rhetoric in response to
that targeting specifically the Supreme
Court justices in Colorado well we've
been always very clear any um any
intimidation uh any violent rhetoric or
violence uh we're certainly going to
denounce that uh and say it's in
appropriate guys it's mostly the violent
rhetoric it's not about the president
not being on the ballot two states it's
the violent rhetoric around that that is
the real threat to democracy I mean this
is Banana Republic level stuff so okay
what do we do in the face of all of this
I I've laid out a pretty a pretty thick
uh case on the show so far today that
there are a lot of problems here and
that again we don't really have the
sense making apparatus to slog through
this I think there are people that are
trying I'm trying I'm sure you're trying
in your life but like at a national
level we just don't have that anymore
and that's partly because of what
technology has done to us and we all can
go off and I listen to this person you
listen to that person you end up living
in very different worlds uh but I think
I've illustrated The Divide in this
country for this upcoming year right it
seems to me that it's anyone to the
right of Bill Maher let's say and billah
is pretty Lefty versus anyone to the
left of say a Sam Harris or or a Seth
McFarland right the individual versus
the system people thus it's basically
anti-woke vers Proke we all know that
but I've also thoroughly showcased that
the Proke ideology not only what it is
uh but how consequential how much damage
it has done uh so far in America and
what it could do if the Democrats get
back into office uh in November and by
the way it's not like the Republicans
are so great but they're just a little
bit better um okay so now I wanted this
is going to be a tricky one for me
because I want to shift a little bit to
something that's happening on the right
right now that I think is super super
dangerous and I sense it's going to get
much worse and I'm desperately going to
try to be one of the people that does
not feed into it uh Tucker
Carlson like Tucker he's been on my show
a couple times he's been to my house
I've been to I've been on his show many
times like I consider us you know
friends to a certain extent whatever uh
Tucker has had a couple strange moments
going after Ben Shapiro lately now
Tucker of course left fox or Fox left
him I guess there's some lawsuits around
that Tucker announced what was it two
three weeks ago that he's bu building a
network uh now Tucker Carlson Network
obviously would be in direct competition
with say a benjiro daily wire Network
and Tucker's been taken some hits on Ben
and I I think they've actually been
pretty bad and I'm only doing this
segment because it is very obvious to me
that Tucker Carlson and Ben Shapiro and
me and you all want to live in the same
country we all know that the woke thing
that communism and socialism and
collectivism that that is the real
danger but because of being in an
election ction year and because of a
Republican primary and everything else
and because of two guys that now have
competing networks there is going to be
a lot of energy focused on everyone
destroying everybody uh and so here I'm
going to I'm going to ever so softly
call out Tucker with the hopes of of
bringing a little healing to this thing
but here is Tucker going after uh Ben
Shapiro this is just a couple days ago I
did think it showed like the level of
not just corruption which I knew but of
like emotional instability and crazy I
mean there are people and I stop reading
any of it but there are people on the
right who have spent the last two months
every single day focused on a conflict
in a foreign country as our own country
becomes dangerously unstable on the
brink of financial collapse with tens of
millions of people who shouldn't be here
in the country we don't know their
identities or the purpose of their being
here like stuff that's could destroy the
country for real and make it impossible
for my kids to live here they've said
nothing about that and they're focused
with laser and intensity on foreign
conflicts and I'm like at some point
I've got four kids if I'm so caught up
in the problems of my neighbor's
children and completely ignoring my own
children as they get addicted to drugs
and kill
themselves you know I'm not against
helping my neighbor kids but clearly I
don't love my kids I mean that's that's
you know that's the only logical
conclusion and they don't care about the
country at all and that's you know
that's kind of their prerogative but I
do because I have no choice cuz I'm from
here my family's been here hundreds of
years I plan to stay here like I I'm
shocked by how little they care about
the country and including the person you
mentioned and I I can't imagine how
someone like that could get an audience
of people who claim about care about
America because he doesn't obviously
right right okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
that is just a seriously low IQ take and
and really lwh hanging fruit and
dishonest by Tucker so Tucker if you're
watching this and maybe I'll send you
this video myself I'll text it to you uh
you you got to do a little a little bit
better than that the idea that Ben
Shapiro does not care about America nor
has been like basically the number one
conservative voice in alt media for the
last decade basically is crazy yes Ben
has spent an awful lot of time over the
last three months talking about Israel
and many people have by the way Tucker
Mr America First Tucker um there are
American hostages still Americans were
killed and there still are American
hostages being held by Hamas in Gaza
right now should Americans not care
about that also as I've said many times
you should be able to walk and chew gum
what have I done on this show for the
last 3 months have I talked about what's
going on in Israel an awful lot of
course but every single day do I talk
about the Border do I talk about the
fenel do I talk about immigration and
the drugs and all of the stuff that's
happening and I have no doubt that Ben
is doing that too so I think in a in a
very cynical cynical move there
unfortunately what Tucker is trying to
do is he's going Ben is my competition
now I building out the Tucker Carlson
Network who who is our competition well
Fox is our competition and the daily
wire is our competition and say the
blaze is our competition and I'm going
to go out and and take out Ben and it's
just not right and it's not good and I
would say beyond anything else beyond
anything else we have a much bigger
problem it is the problem that I've
spent the first 52 minutes of this show
talking about and if we're going to make
this about a personal beef or because we
have our own business decisions that are
that are going to take precedence over
the importance of the country then we
are effed already Beyond imagination
that's exactly where we will be I want
to just read you one tweet from Andrew
claven who of course I've had on the
show a million times who is a good
friend of mine he's on the daily wire
and uh I thought he summed this up
nicely referring to what Tucker just
said there he wrote balls anyone who
says Ben Shapiro isn't a patriot is
either a fool or a liar I don't know
what's happened to Tucker Carlson I'm
not going to pretend to read his mind or
his motives but his remark is in keeping
with the quality of his content as of
late you know Andrew is the most like
sort of softspoken like he does not like
going after anybody nobody wants to
including me wants to go after Tucker
and unleash the the Bots and the trolls
and the army of Maga people and
everything else but we cannot waste time
trying to take out Ben Shapiro or trying
to take out people who we agree with on
stuff 90% of the way uh in light of
what's going on on the other side if
everything was freaking right now if we
had a border if we had cities that were
operating properly and we wanted to do
the infighting thing like I want you to
watch my show more than you watch this
guy's show and he talks too fast and I
wear my shirts like this okay fine but
we will lose this country we will hand
it to the woke maybe we've done that
already but we will hand it to them on a
silver freaking platter if we do not
decide there is something greater that
we have in common and that we better
freaking fix it save it before it's over
so let's shift a little bit more we're
going big on this uh first show of 2024
uh I want to shift a little bit to
presidential politics because I think in
I think if I'm not mistaken Iowa caucus
January 15th is that right so we've got
basically uh 14 days uh 13 days to the
January caucus okay and uh by every
estimation conventional wisdom every
poll everything else Trump is going to
win this thing in a landslide I want to
read you though a post that Trump put up
on Truth social over the weekend because
uh he was getting some push back even
from a few of his own people but just
tell me if this if this is the thing
that you want going forward this is
Donald Trump on uh truth social uh going
after he's going after chip Roy here
because chip Roy uh has def has uh
endorsed Ronda sandis this is he's ret
retr I suppose a guy by the name of Paul
and Gracia uh it doesn't matter how
conservative a meaningless term chip
soy's voting record record is he is a
political hack with horrible judgment
and character he has never accomplished
anything of significance in his life and
committed the ultimate Act of betrayal
by going against Donald Trump in the
America first movement he's disgraced to
Texas and isn't even worthy of being a
dog catcher now Trump put that up
doesn't matter who this Paul guy is um
Trump put that up chip Roy from Texas
I've had him on the show a couple times
actually he has the most conservative
voting record in Congress period you can
fact check that for yourself now he
happens to think that Ronda santis would
be a better choice for president Trump
and this is what I would relate to the
sort of Ben Shapiro Tucker thing Trump
is basically like you are with me or
against me I will burn everybody down
and Trump will gladly take out I mean
this is just obvious and I'm sorry if
you're more on the Maga side of this
thing and and it might damn well be true
that in a month from now Trump will have
this thing locked up and I will I will
continue living it will be okay we'll of
the show and everything else I do not
think we'll have made the right choice
but there we are and we'll adjust
accordingly okay just fine um but Trump
will gladly I mean what he's trying to
do right there is turn all of Maga
against the congressman who is the most
conservative more conservative than me
right that's what he's trying to do and
then the name calling and everything
else okay so is that what we're going to
do is that how we're going to beat the
woke in in 2024 by alienating all of the
anti-woke people just because they won't
bow to Trump well then Trump had another
one I mean this is just another one uh
This is Wild this is Trump himself over
the weekend the FBI headquarters should
not be moved to a farway location but
should stay right here where it is in a
new and spectacular building in the best
location in our now crimer ridden and
filthy dirty graffiti scarred Capital
they should be involved in bringing back
DC not running away from it especially
the violent crime an important part of
my platform fore for president is to
bring back restore and rebuild
Washington DC into the crown jewel of
our nation we will make it crime-free
and great again the FBI should not be
fleeing for safer yet much less
convenient environs it should be make it
should make where they are now the
safest place on Earth don't move the FBI
um he is tweeting this out or he's truth
soing this thing out because Ronda
santis amongst other people I think VC
as well have said that we should move
the FBI if we decentralize government
right the Department of Education and
the Department of Agriculture and the
FBI all these things that are so
centralized in DC that's what the swamp
is about right when you have all of
these people and all these people know
each other and go to dinner with each
other and everything else and the
lobbyists are all there that DC has
become the very type of centralized
power that the founders were trying to
escape when they founded this country
250 years ago right and here's Trump
defending the swamp that we're going to
put more money into DC and we're going
to give the FBI a new building do you
think the
FBI or the CIA or the Department of
Education or the Department of
Agriculture anything they deserve a new
building and who cares at this point if
if DC is crimer ridden but Trump is kind
of in it for the swamp at this point uh
Thomas Massie who I think has the second
most conservative voting record who is
by far the most Libertarian member
individual rights anti government member
of Congress from Kentucky uh he tweeted
this out let's be clear the FBI does not
need a spectacular new building I mean
any of you watching this right now do
you think the idea right now is that the
FBI should get a new building and any
one red cent of your dollars should go
to the FBI getting a new building I mean
that's just crazy so then there's this
account and I know we're getting into
the weeds here a little bit but I'm just
trying to illustrate this provide right
now that that either we will continue to
fester and and just demolish the
Republican party and we will be left
with the woke Democrats running
everything or we can try to heal some of
this stuff right now and I think the
only way you can heal anything is
through truth so then there's this
account cat turd which is a huge account
on Twitter Anonymous Big Maga guy I
don't think he particularly likes me he
wrote uh let's be clear the Republican
Party give them everything they wanted
and renewed fisa amazing you're talking
when you failed so miserably he's
talking to Thomas Massie about that
let's be clear the FBI does not need a
spectacular new building and Thomas
Massie wrote I voted against that this
is your guy how does the kitty litter
taste that was pretty good by Massie I
do like
Massie okay you get it guys you get it
we can have all of these little
bickerings these little fights we can
have over-the-top comments and and and
just we'll try to take out Ben Shapiro
and we'll try to build the FBI new
building or we can all kind of get
together right now and work this thing
out I'm not bullish that we can actually
do it because that's not you know it's
not the way the system of pressures
works with humans um I'm bullish that we
can do it in in individual states
perhaps and elsewhere um but I would say
that from say Bill
Maher most likely will vote the wrong
way but gets the big issues right uh to
someone like Tucker who gets the big
issues right and yet I think is making a
little mistake here I do think there is
a path it's the anti-woke path it's the
anti-woke campaign uh it's it's
something bigger it's something bigger
than all of our little bickering so we
can have we can have our own Javier
Malay right he is the new president of
uh Argentina and he is he is ripping
apart the woke right now he is ripping
apart their Mass uh their huge ever
expanding government he's doing it right
now we'll get to him in just a second
but before we do I want to throw back
back to a clip from uh this is probably
about a year and a half ago you may
remember Dr Robert Malone he was the he
is the Doctor Who has the most patents
as it becomes as it pertains to mRNA
technology than anyone and yet he has
come out uh very much against the MRNA
vaccines he was on Joe Rogan's show
we've shown you this clip before and
here he is talking about how we are
living through something called Mass
formation psychosis that we are all sort
of Trapped in this in this information
war that is making us believe things
that are not true and do you think it's
possible if you live in something like
that you might start aiming at the wrong
people instead of aiming at the obvious
thing doing it to you so take a look
from basically European intellectual
inquiry into what the heck happened in
Germany in the 20s and 30s you know very
intelligent highly educated population
and they went barking mad um and how did
that happen um the answer is mass
formation psychosis when you have a
society that has become decoupled from
each other and has free floating anxiety
and a sense that things don't make sense
we can't understand it and then their
attention gets focused by a leader or a
series of events on one small point just
like
hypnosis they literally become
hypnotized and can be led anywhere and
one of the aspects of that phenomena is
the people that they identify as their
leaders the ones typically that come in
and say you have this pain and I can
solve it for you I and I alone okay can
fix this problem for you okay then they
will lead they will follow that person
through it doesn't matter whether they
lie to him or whatever the data are
irrelevant and furthermore anybody who
questions that narrative is to be
immediately attacked they are the
other this is Central to mass formation
psychosis and this is what has happened
we had all those conditions if you
remember back before 2019 everybody was
complaining the world doesn't make sense
blah blah blah um and we're all isolated
from each other we're all on our little
tools we're not connected socially
anymore except through social media um
and then this thing happened and
everybody focused on it that is how Mass
formation psychosis happens and that is
what's happened here doesn't that sound
exactly like what I've been talking
about right our sens makers blown apart
we just don't have trusted institutions
we have very few trusted people at this
point then anyone who says anything
against say the dear leader right what's
going to happen to you they will go
after you right Tucker going after Ben
like he knows Ben is not the enemy here
he has his own reasons why he's doing it
but this thing that is happening to all
of us we are focused all on the wrong
things as the authoritarians come right
if you think right now if you are it's
not even a Republican or a conservative
or anything else if you are a
liberty-minded decent American if you
think that chip Roy and Thomas Massie
are the problem like the most
conservative libertarian guys in
Congress if you think they're the
problem because they will not bow to the
dear leader then you maybe only need a
mirror so we will only win if the rest
of us unite to break out of this thing
and you know what it is possible because
look what's going on in Argentina right
now this is absolutely spectacular this
is from the N wokeness Twitter account
18 days ago president Javier Malay was
inaugurated in Argentina since then
here's what he's done this is
unbelievable eliminated 12 out of 21
cabinet posts firing 5,000 government
employees ending 380,000 government
regulations banned woke language in the
military Bill to affirm the right to
self-defense Bill to legalize
homeschooling of kids proposal to punish
app to punish all Riot organizers future
welfare cuts for Road blocking legalized
paying contracts in Bitcoin
privatization of state-run companies
opened up the Argentina oil industry
doesn't that all sound freaking amazing
and it's because the people of Argentina
had gotten so close to the precipice of
true communism and socialism socialism
they had basically dived into it already
they were in that pool and they somehow
figured out how to get out and they're
on their way out and every single bullet
point that I just put up there are the
things that we should be doing here in
the United States now we're not doing
them at the federal level but guess what
there are some places where we're doing
some of those things and yes I don't
think in my first show that is now 65
minutes in of the year that I have said
anything about the free state of Florida
so here we go this is a tweet by Eric
doy about what's happening right now in
Florida Florida Republicans are getting
ready for another crazy session and
we've got some bullet points for you
loosening firearm purchasing
restrictions protecting historical
monuments no LGBT flags on public
property no business with newsguard
censorship companies further Crackdown
on adversary influence more return
seized weapons more promptly the santis
budget slashing government jobs tax cuts
protecting crypto expanding who can
exempt themselves from vaccine
requirements stricter penalties on
people who flee police Banning pronoun
requirements and penalties more Banning
lab grown meat revoking Financial
benefits for college students who
support Hamas pregnancy SLP parting
resources Insurance improvements healthc
care improvements an effort to ban
reparations for slavery so do you see it
guys have we laid out a case on this
first show of the year it can be done
and it's being done in certain places
but it doesn't just need to be done in
Argentina and it doesn't just need to be
done in the Free State of Florida it
needs to be expanded and it needs to be
done in every state and I get it certain
States won't do it certain people won't
wake up uh but we have 14 days 13 days
till that primary there is a choice to
be made and you can either choose to
give the FBI a brand spanking new
building in the middle of the swamp as
you claim you're draining the swamp and
you can choose to try to destroy all of
the true conservative voices whether
they're Thomas Massie Chi Roy or Ben
Shapiro you can choose to do that you
can choose to do that
or you could choose to do something else
I think you know what I've chosen know
who the enemy is let's fix let's fix
this freaking thing guys people of the
internet is live at 1M postgame show
right now Ruben report. locals.com new
Twitter account Ruben report show if you
want to get all of our clips
and I don't think I took one exhale
during that entire show all right there
you go all right thanks for watching
everybody see you later New Direction
One Direction whatever
hold on I got to block my betas real
quick cheers to all of you at home Happy
New
Year that was a big one even for
me John you are in I can't see Anderson
but I know exactly what he looks like
yes yes yes you do yes you do he's gone
he's off with the fairies here um just
the shot of the cat's ass in your face
is making him
Delirious
[Music]
um